in a desperate attempt to assert to
dominate their Domination by punishing
their insubordinates the United States
has taken the path of destroying
globalization which for many years they
have taunted they have raised up as the
highest benefit of all of human of
humanity advancing the multilateral
system of global economic system
Washington and it's a western
subordinates leverage those rules every
time they need to justify illegitimate
attempts against those who base their
policies in line with international law
and those who
abandon the parochial interests of the
global billion the Western colleagues
have long found it inconvenient to reach
agreement through Universal formats such
as the United Nations for ideological
Justified policy to undermine a
multilateralism in abandonment of
democracy encountering uh autocracy
Beyond The Summit for demand accuracy
where self-proclaimed has
self-proclaimed a hegemon determines
composition there are other clubs of
Select individuals are adopted the
summit for democracy the alliance for
multilateralism the global partnership
for artificial interact the global
Coalition for freedom of media the Paris
called for trust and Security in
cyberspace all of these and other
exclusive projects have been devised to
undermine
negotiations on relevant themes under
the ages of the United Nations to impose
a non-consensual Concepts and decisions
that are convenient for the west and
these are proposed as a position of the
International Community let's call a
spade a spade nobody allowed the Western
minority to speak on behalf of all of
humankind